[Applauso]
da 24 anni io penso che il teatro sia il
luogo dell'osservazione e della
relazione innanzitutto tra persone e
penso che sia il luogo estremamente
funzionale per le persone perché al suo
interno si creano e si formano materie
assolutamente riferite a uomini e donne
da 24 anni o pratico il lavoro l'attrice
è a fianco da 17 anni a questo lavoro
quello di condurre laboratori in ambito
scolastico educativo e in ambito
psichiatrico come avete sentito e quindi
in dipartimenti di salute mentale ed è
proprio a partire dal lavoro d'attore
che vorrei raccontare come secondo me è
il perché il teatro sia il luogo
bellissimo del prendersi cura di sé
delle persone e finanche delle cose e
allora il luogo del laboratorio teatrale
è un luogo in cui si svolge l'attività
della persona che è traslata però
nell'attore la sua attività è costituita
da un'attività fisica e quindi muscolare
e anche da un'attività intellettuale
cognitiva cioè attraverso i sensi io
cerco di contattare la realtà che fuori
da me quella che riesco a conoscere e
questo lo facciamo con due l'attore lo
fa con due obiettivi con l'obiettivo di
capire comprendere quelle che sono le
parole che costituiscono il corpo
dell'attore per ente scusate del
personaggio per interpretarlo è anche
per metterlo nel corpo quindi
comprendere e mettere nel corpo quelle
che sono le parole dell'attore ora in
questo rapporto secondo me dell'attore
con il linguaggio con il ripercorrere
questo linguaggio
esiste un movimento molto interessante
che replica costantemente l'aspirazione
dell'uomo ad essere in qualche misura
libero
libero probabilmente anche dalle parole
quindi per prima cosa quello che si
realizza in questo movimento tra
personaggio persona attore e parole è un
circolo virtuoso
un movimento che tenta di liberare
l'uomo dal condizionamento delle parole
in ambito psichiatrico quando si sente
parlare di stigma si fa riferimento a un
segno a una parola qualcosa che si legge
in faccia al malato che si posiziona nel
corpo e da lì è difficile che si sposti
ora quindi analizzare il percorso
dell'attore nel gioco nel dialogo con le
parole significa proprio cercare come
per tutte le persone di dare la
possibilità di mettere in discussione la
propria condizione la condizione quindi
di ciascuno figurarsi per il malato
mentale la persona che fatica ad avere
delle relazioni sociali è in difficoltà
prendersi cura quindi e ritornando al
teatro e cercando di capire il valore
che il teatro ha in ambito di salute
mentale quindi in ambito anche educativo
per ciascuno di noi dobbiamo considerare
che la persona è quella che fa che
costituisce l'attore
le parole sono quelle che costituiscono
il personaggio è l'attore che cosa fa
sostanzialmente utilizza le parole del
personaggio le veste le osserva le
accarezza le mette su di sé per riuscire
a realizzare quello che è il personaggio
tramite l'interpretazione perché noi che
guardiamo dobbiamo riuscire a
riconoscere che ecco quello che vedo è
effettivamente amleto perché amleto
quando dice essere o non essere
cammina per il palco e si muove
diversamente da riccardo iii che invece
dice l'inverno del nostro scontento
eccetera eccetera e gobbo e da qualità i
rapporti di movimento diverso
dicevo in questo rapporto dell'attore
che è persona si sviluppa
l'interpretazione ma l'attore che è
traslato dalla persona in realtà
realizza questo quando attinge alla
propria sensibilità alla propria
capacità fisica
e cosa accade accade che simpaticamente
l'attore impattando le parole
utilizzandole facendo le saltellare e
mettendole su di sé rende estremamente
vivo il linguaggio ma soprattutto il
rapporto che lui ha con le parole
cosa accade in realtà le parole
saltellano vive si formano entrano in
relazione con le cose è un gioco che in
qualche modo dovremmo ricordare perché
da bimbetti le parole collegate alle
cose quando eravamo piccoli scaturivano
così nel tentativo di intercettare una
realtà fuori da noi ma cosa accade nelle
thaad ulta non è più così questa potenza
pura del sorgere delle parole un poco si
assopisce probabilmente con l'abitudine
o probabilmente con l'attitudine che
abbiamo di credere vere e di conoscere
per vere le cose ma le parole non sono
le cose
ed ecco allora che in questo gioco della
relazione il teatro forse iniziamo a
intuire quale tipo di potenza possa
scaturire a tutti gli effetti è per
tutti di conseguenza nel laboratorio
teatrale in ambito di salute mentale io
di solito accade così che arrivò e dico
agli astanti presenti i miei colleghi di
laboratorio dico bene adesso qui noi
faremo teatro e loro rispondono
solitamente no no no no no io non le
faccio quelle robe lì no no non mi
interessa io lo so che cos'è il teatro
non lo voglio fare non sono capaci e mi
vergogno non ho scuse
allora facciamo così io dico non
chiamiamolo teatro non lo chiamiamo
affatto facciamo facciamo qualcosa
insieme
cioè cosa facciamo bene per esempio dico
io vorrei mettere adesso una musica e
vorrei che in questa musica noi ci
muovessimo liberamente chi no no io non
ballo non ho io non voglio ballare mi
vergogno in mezzo a tutti tutti mi
guardano no scusa dico io
io non ho detto ballare ho detto ci
muoviamo bene se io riesco a fare
accadere qualcosa di interessante con il
mezzo del gioco qualcosa di non stupido
o è di troppo in qualche modo
e strano ecco che qualcosa nel gruppo di
lavoro cambia il gruppo di lavoro che
incontrò in ambito di salute mentale è
molto vario e difficile è difficile far
penetrare il lavoro dell'attore
all'interno di questa situazione perché
le persone che incontro appunto sono
induriti nel corpo sono indurite nelle
giunture si palesa un blocco nella
persona io lo vedo e le persone lo
dicono io sono bloccato non riesco
faccio fatica
non riesco a relazionarmi ma come posso
cambiare ecco che allora la forma del
gioco attraverso il teatro acquista un
senso particolare succede qualcosa di
diverso allora noi mettiamo la musica
che non volevamo ascoltare e iniziamo a
muoverci nel corpo muoversi nel corpo
per una persona che porta nel corpo un
dolore non è una cosa così immediata ma
tutto si risolve scartando il tema della
forma del lavoro e del movimento del
corpo che compiamo non c'è nessuna forma
nessuna pratica nessun riferimento a
qualche tipo di danza qualche tipo di di
movimento che ci costringerebbe ad
entrare in un canone
e allora iniziamo a parlare di giunture
e allora iniziamo a capire se il polso
esiste che possibilità ha e che cosa
presenta sotto le dita e come si
coniugano con il polso ed al polso
passiamo al braccio alla spalla ed ecco
che accade che il mio pensiero il mio
pensiero di me che agisco è realmente
nel corpo ma non sono solo parole e non
è una forma strana o visionaria di
approcciare il corpo nel laboratorio
teatrale è proprio la possibilità che io
ho di stare con ciò che faccio gli occhi
sono a posto anche se si spostano da qua
le orecchie sono a posto io ascolto la
musica e faccio se il pensiero la mia
attenzione si allontana dal corpo io lo
vedo lo segnalo e chiedo di rientrare
dentro questa condizione di assoluto
senso dell'ordine quello che accade nei
laboratori e proprio questo attraverso
il corpo io percepisco la possibilità
dell'ordine di qualcosa di carezzevole
qualcosa che soprattutto io conduco in
maniera libera libera dal
condizionamento quindi non solo delle
parole ma anche dell'utilizzo del corpo
che come è naturale è facile comprendere
torna a rifiorire
ma cosa accade nella rifioritura sia
nelle parole e sia nell'utilizzo del
corpo accadono cose particolari quando
io parlo
il mezzo formidabile della parola
utilizzata dall attore che io replico
nel laboratorio teatrale è che per
impattare la parola io devo usare la mia
voce
lo strumento della voce che impatta le
parole crea un circolo virtuoso di
relazione per cui semplicemente il
sangue circola magari un pochino di più
il riciclo del sangue e un pochino più
accentuato e alla fine arriva anche un
po di buonumore a dire il vero poi nella
classe succede che a un certo punto è
possibile che attraverso l'indicazione
io abbia la percezione di uno spazio che
attorno a me si muove semplicemente
facendo un piccolo spostamento quando
l'attore decide di spostare una sedia
ecco che c'è la percezione chiara che
tutto cambi e si sposti attorno a me se
anche la sposto solo di 45 gradi cambia
il mio rapporto spaziale il mio fronte
diventa questo so che voi siete lì ma se
il mio collega alle mie spalle se prima
a lui ho detto amore
ora se io lo devo dire in quest'altro in
quest'altra visione e postura spaziale
io ruoterò di 45 gradi la mia testa
so che lui è lì e questo dire amore
cambia ora è molto importante secondo me
avere anche solo la sensazione della
possibilità che fuori da me la realtà
possa cambiare
laddove il malato mentale la persona in
difficoltà o il bambino che deve
crescere non c'è distinzione apprende
fisicamente lo sente nel corpo oppure
nella voce che qualcosa può cambiare
beh succedono cose veramente molto
interessanti
e allora io decido che da questa
mobilità noi possiamo iniziare a giocare
il gioco consiste proprio nell usare il
lavoro che io conosco sull'attore
l'attore deve sviluppare un certo numero
di azioni che sa svolgere e sempre
maggiore è il numero deve essere
allenato nel corpo pronto reattivo la
voce deve essere duttile pronta a
cambiare di tono ad impattare quelle
parole a mettere in campo quel circolo
che è virtuoso di restituzione da parte
della parola impattata di questa grande
energia che è vitale
certo non è così semplice perché in
realtà c'è una grande reticenza il
malato è appunto quella costituito in
una classe che il più delle volte
appunto dice no io non ho voglia ed è
variabile perché se una settimana fa
aveva voglia di fare anche due giorni fa
oggi non ce l'ha più e non è semplice
bisogna trovare il modo di come fare e
come fare e significato semplicemente
non avere programmi cioè non decidere
nulla del da farsi con la classe di
lavoro ma restare aperta a una sorta di
dialogo costante quindi un rapporto che
si sviluppa tra me e il collega di
laboratorio o se volete il paziente in
maniera molto naturale dialogante non è
mai un rapporto in positivo da parte mia
anche se io sono molto energica in ciò
che dico non c'è pietismo nei nostri
rapporti c'è un rapporto che tende ad
essere paritario e quindi molto normale
e da questo rapporto possono scaturire
delle cose molto interessanti si
realizza una sorpresa ma non la mia
perché io li vedo sempre all'interno e
soltanto all'interno del laboratorio
teatrale per me sono sempre bravissimi
la sorpresa in realtà è riportata dagli
operatori i quali sono con noi nel
laboratorio teatrale vedono il lavoro
che svolgiamo insieme lo fanno e poi
seguono il paziente nel percorso di cura
oltre il laboratorio teatrale di solito
il rimando è che se di fronte al
personale sanitario
le persone sono chiuse reticenti a
parlare
quasi immobilizzate nel laboratorio
teatrale accade qualcosa di diverso
certo bisogna impostarlo da un punto di
vista del gioco del saperlo in qualche
modo trattare siamo sempre noi alla
ricerca del nostro modo di agire
le parole e le cose io credo fermamente
che il valore del teatro e la carezza
fondamentale del teatro che io ho
cercato di presentare declinato nel
lavoro dell'attore cioè di colui che
impatta le parole che mette in campo
questo circolo virtuoso di relazione poi
replicato nel teatro che è una somma di
relazioni
penso che dicevo la carezza del teatro
consista proprio in questo cioè nel
segnalare che tra il personaggio
l'attore le parole e la persona c'è una
piccola distanza da colmare e
attraversando questa distanza si crea un
movimento che esorta chi lo fa o anche
chi lo osserva a concludere che c'è una
distanza fantastica tra le parole e
l'essere ed è questo che senza scomodare
nessun tipo di ragione del ragionamento
particolare o filosofico ma entrando nel
corpo dell'attore nella pratica che fa
dell'uso del proprio corpo e delle
parole si percepisca in modo tale che lo
stigma di cui abbiamo parlato quelle
parole che a volte si appiccicano
sull'essere in questa distanza praticata
possano smettere di immobilizzare le
persone e quindi in sostanza in questa
pratica fantastica fare riecheggiare
nella persona la possibilità di sentirsi
liberi liberi nella misura in cui si
ridiventa in qualche misura autori del
nostro parlare autori del nostro parlare
in relazione il teatro è tutto questo
il lavoro dell'attore non fa che fare
spostare e fare ballare tutte quante le
parole grazie
[Applauso]